OPEN KOWT FOR THE
E TO
SWEEP THE SERIES AWAY FROM THE
AND LOOK. PICKS UP THE  VUCEVIC
BLOCK BY BAM. THINK SHE HAS
ONLY  MISSED THE SHOT BUT DID
NOT GET A WHISTLE.CITY AND THE
WALKIEIE BASKET.
AND HE GOT IT!TEAM, AS A
WHOLE, BECAUSE THEY'RE A
MONK SMILES AT PORTER AS THEY -!
JACK FOUR
HE PLAYED IN HOUSTON THAT LAST
SEQUENCE THERE FOR JALEN  BrianN
>> Stan: WOW. THUMPER.
GIVES ACCESS TO THE BASELINE.
CADE CUNNINGHAM AND HE MADE IT
PAYULD TURN OUT TO BE. TO GET
HIM SWITCHED ONTO RUSSELL
WESTBROOK.
>> Mike: TECHNICAL FOULS
ALREADY.
>> Ian: DINWIDDIE THAT DUNK, LUA
FOUR TO PLAY.
JRUE LEANING SWALLOW THEIR
WHISTLES IN THAT SITUAT TEMPO
DIFFERENCE WHEN DEMAR IS OFF
DERRICK JONES JR. MAKING SURE
THE PARTY CONTINUES IN THIS
THIRD QUARTER. WIN!
OH!UP, THROW IT BACK,
KNOCK DOWN THE THREE. IT UP.
WOW.
>> Joel: YOU SAW THAT WILLY HAD
HIS SIX.
MORANT BLOWS BY PRIMA. HITS YOU.
MORANT!
OH MY GOODNESS!
IT IS JA MORANT